The only solution for this equation, is positive 8. Great algebra skills for
getting this one correct. We'll take the same steps to try and solve this.
First we'll isolate the radical on one side of the equation. And lucky for us,
it already is. Next we'll square both sides, and then try and factor our
quadratic. When we square both sides, we'll get ax squared minus 6a plus 9 on
the left, and 3a plus 1 on the right. We move these terms to the other side of
the equation, so that way we can set it equal to 0. We factor a squared minus
9a plus 8, since the factors of 8 that sum to negative 9 are negative 1 and
negative 8. We solve for the factors of a by setting each factor equal to 0.
So, a could be positive 8 or a could be positive 1. Next we want to check
positive 8 and positive 1 in the original equation. Plugging in x equals 8, we
get a true statement of 5 equals 5. When we plug in x equals 1, we don't end up
with a true statement. We'll have negative 2 equals 2. Since this doesn't
check, we know x equals 1 is not part of our solution set. We'll just have the
answer x equals 8.